YUFEI ZHAO: For the
past few lectures,
we've been discussing the
structure of set addition,
and which culminated in the
proof of Freiman's theorem.
So this was a pretty
big and central result
in additive combinatorics,
which gives you
a complete characterization
of sets with small doubling.
Today, I want to look at a
somewhat different issue also
related to sets
of small doubling,
but this time we want to
have a somewhat different
characterization of what does
it mean for a set to have
lots of additive structure.
So in today's
lecture, we're always
going to be working
in an Abelian group.
Let me define the
following quantity.
Given sets A and B, we
define the additive energy
between A and B to be
denoted by E of A and B.
So A and B are subgroups.
They're subsets of this
arbitrary Abelian group.
So E of A and B is defined to
be the number of quadruples, a1,
a2, b1, b2, where a1, a2
are elements of A, and b1,
b2 are elements of B,
such that a1 plus b1
equals to a2 plus b2.
So the additive
energy is the number
of quadruples of these
elements where you
have this additive relation.
And we would like
to understand sets
with large additive energy.
So, intuitively, if you
have lots of solutions
to this equation in
your sets, then the
sets themselves should have lots
of internal additive structure.
So it's a different way of
describing additive structure,
and we'd like to
understand how does
this way of describing
additive structure
relate to things we've seen
before, namely small doubling.
When you have not two
sets but just one set--
slightly easier to think about--
we just write E of A.
I mean E of A comma A.
And these objects are analogous
to 4 cycles in graph theory.
Because if you about this
expression here in a Cayley
graph, let's say
over F2, then this
is the description of a 4 cycle.
You go around 4
steps, and you come
back to where you started from.
So these objects are
the analogs of 4 cycles.
And we already saw in our
discussion of quasi-randomness,
and also elsewhere,
that 4 cycles
play an important
role in graph theory.
And, likewise, these
additive energies
are going to play an important
role in describing sets
with additive structure.
Consider the following quantity.
We're going to let r sub A comma
B of x to be the number of ways
to write x as a plus b.
So x equals to a plus b.
So r sub A comma B of
x is the number of ways
I can write x as a plus b, where
a comes from big A, little b
comes from big B. Then,
reinterpreting the formula
up there, we see that the
additive energy between two
sets A and B is simply the sum
of the squares of A-- r sub A
comma B. As x ranges over
all elements of the group,
we only need to take x
in the sumset A plus B.
So the basic question,
like when we discussed
additive combinatorics, in the
sense of when we discussed sets
of small doubling,
there we asked,
if you have a set A of a certain
size, how big can a plus a be?
Here, let's ask the same.
If I give you set A of a certain
size, how big or how small
can the additive
energy of the set be?
What's the most number
of possible number
of additive quadruples.
What's the least possible
number of additive quadruples?
There's some
trivial bounds, just
like in the case of sumsets.
So what are some trivial bounds?
On one hand, by taking a1 equal
to a2, and b2 equal to b2,
we see that the energy is
always at least the square
of the size of A.
On the other hand,
if I fix three of
the four elements,
then the fourth
element is determined.
So the upper bound is
cube of the size of A.
And you convince
yourself that, except up
to maybe a constant
factors, this
is the best possible general
upper and lower bound.
Similar situation with sumsets,
where you have lower bound
linear, upper bound quadratic.
Which is the side with
additive structure?
So if you have lots
of additive structure,
you have high energy.
So this range is when you have
lots of additive structure.
And we would like to
understand, what can you
say about a set with
high additive energy?
Well, what are some examples of
sets with high additive energy?
It turns out that if
you have a set that
has small doubling,
then, automatically,
it implies large
additive energy.
So, in particular, intervals,
or GAPs, or a large subset
of GAPs, or all these examples
that we saw-- in fact,
these are all the examples
coming from Freiman's theorem.
Also, arbitrary groups.
You can have subgroups.
And so all of these examples
have large additive energy.
So let me-- I'll you the
proof just in a second.
It's not hard.
But the real question is,
what about the converse?
So can you see much in
the reverse direction?
But, first, let me show you
this claim that small doubling
implies large additive energy.
Well, if you have small
doubling, if a plus A is size,
at most, k times
the size of A, then
it turns out the
additive energy of A
is at least the
maximum possible,
which is A cubed divided by k.
So that's within a constant
factor of the maximum.
It's pretty large.
If you have small doubling,
then large additive energy.
So let's see the proof.
So you can often
tell how hard a proof
is by how simple the statement
is, although that's not always
the case, as we've seen
with some of our theorems,
like Plunnecke's inequality.
But in this case, it turns
out to be fairly simple.
So we see that r sub A comma
A is supported on A plus A.
So we use Cauchy-Schwarz
to write--
so, first, we write additive
energy in terms of the sum
of the squares of these r's.
And now, by Cauchy-Schwarz,
we find that you can replace
the sum of the squared
r's by the sum of the r's.
But now the key point
here is that we take out
this factor coming from
Cauchy-Schwarz, which is only
A plus A. So if the support size
is small, we gain in this step.
But what is the sum of r's?
I mean, r of x is
just number of ways
to write x as little
a1 plus little ab--
little a2.
So if I sum over all x, I'm just
looking at different two ways--
we're just looking at ways of
picking an ordered pair from A.
So this last expression
is equal to the size of A
to power 4 divided by
A plus A. And now we
use that A has small
doubling to conclude
that the final quantity is at
least A cubed divided by k.
So we see small doubling
implies large additive energy.
And this kind of makes sense.
If your set doesn't
expand, then there
are many collisions of sums.
And so you must have lots of
solutions to that equation
up there.
But what about the converse?
If I give you a set with
large additive energy,
must it necessarily
have small doubling?
Oh.
Let me show you an example.
So, well-- so a large
additive energy,
does it imply small doubling?
So consider the
following example, where
you take a set A which
is a combination,
is a union of a set
with small doubling
plus a bunch of elements
without additive structure.
So I take a set
with small doubling
plus a bunch of elements
without additive structure.
Then it has large additive
energy, just coming
from this interval itself.
So the energy of A
is order N cubed.
N is the number of elements.
What about A plus A?
Well, for A plus A,
this part doesn't--
that's the part
that contributes,
or the part of this A
without additive structure.
And we see that the
size of A plus A
is quadratic in the size of A.
So, unfortunately,
the converse fails.
So you can have sets that have
large additive energy and also
large doubling.
But, you see, the reason why
this has large additive energy
is because there is a very
highly structured additively
structured piece of it.
And, somehow, we want to forget
about this extra garbage.
And that's part of the reason
why the converse is not true.
So we would like
a statement that
says that if you have
large additive energy, then
it must come from some
highly structured piece that
has small doubling.
And that is true, and
that's the content
of the Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
theorem, which
is the main topic today.
So the Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
theorem says that if you have
a set--
so we're working always in
some arbitrary Abelian group.
If you have a set
with large energy,
then there exists some
subset A prime of A such
that A prime is a fairly
large proportion of A.
And here, by large I mean up to
polynomial changes in the error
parameters.
So this A prime is such that
A prime has small doubling.
If you have large
additive energy,
then I can pick out a large
piece with small doubling
constant, and I only
loose a polynomial
in the error factors.
So that's the
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers theorem,
and it describes
this example up here.
Any questions about
the statement?
So what I will actually show you
is a slight variant, actually
a more general statement, where,
instead of having one set,
we're going to have two sets.
So here's Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
theorem version
2, where now we have two sets.
Again, A and B are--
I'm not going to write any--
I'm not going to write
it in this lecture,
but A and B are always subsets
of some arbitrary Abelian
group.
So A and B both have
size of, at most,
n, and the energy
between A and B is large.
Then there exists a subset A
prime of A, B prime of B such
that both A prime
and B prime are
large fractions of
their parent set,
and such that A prime
plus B prime is not
too much bigger than n.
It's not so obvious
why the second version
implies the first version.
So you can say, well, take
A and B to be the same.
But then the
conclusion gives you
possibly two different
subsets, A prime and B prime.
But the first version,
I only want one subset
that has small doubling.
So, fortunately,
the second version
does imply the first version.
So let's see why.
The second version implies the
first version because, if we--
so there's a tool
that we introduced
early on when we discussed
Freiman's theorem,
and this is the Ruzsa
triangle inequality.
So the spirit of Ruzsa
triangle inequality
is it allows you to
relate, to sort of go
back and forth between different
sumsets in different sets.
So by Ruzsa triangle inequality,
if we apply the second version
with A equals to B, then--
and we pick out this
A prime and B prime,
then we see that A
prime plus A prime
is, at most, A prime plus B
prime squared over B prime.
Well, actually, this uses the--
vice versa it uses a
slightly stronger version
that we had to use
Plunnecke-Ruzsa key lemma
to prove.
But you can come up--
I mean, if you don't care
about the precise loss
in the polynomial
factors, you can also
use the basic Ruzsa
triangle inequality
to deduce a similar statement.
This is easier to deduce.
So you have that.
And now, the second
version tells you
that the numerator
is, at most, poly kn,
and the denominator
is, at most-- at least,
n divided by poly k.
Remember, over here, to get this
hypothesis, we automatically
have that the size
of A and B are not
two much smaller than n.
Or else this cannot be true.
So putting all these estimates
together, we get that.
So these two versions, they
are equivalent to each other.
Second version
implies the first.
The second one is stronger.
The first one is
slightly more useful.
They're not
necessarily equivalent,
but the second one is stronger.
Any questions?
All right.
So this is a
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers theorem.
So the content of
today's lecture
is to show you how to
prove this theorem.
A remark about the
naming of this theorem.
So you might notice that
these three letters do not
coming in alphabetical order.
And the reason is that
this theorem was initially
approved by Balog and
Szemeredi, but using
a more involved
method that didn't
give polynomial high bounds.
And Gowers, in his proof
of Szemeredi's theorem,
his new proof of Szemeredi's
theorem with good bounds,
he required--
well, he looked
into this theorem
and gave a new
proof that resulted
in this polynomial type bounds.
And it is that idea that
we're going to see today.
So this course is called
graph theory and additive
combinatorics.
And the last two
topics of this course--
today being
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers,
and tomorrow we're going to
see sum-product problem--
are both great
examples of problems
in additive combinatorics
where tools from graph theory
play an important role
in their solutions.
So it's a nice combination
of the subject where we see
both topics at the same time.
So I want to show you the proof
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers,
and the proof goes
via a graph analog.
So I'm going to state for
you a graphical version
of the Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
theorem.
And it goes like this.
If G is a bipartite graph
between vertex sets A and B--
and here A and B are still
subsets of the Abelian group--
we define this restricted
sumset, A plus sub G of B,
to be the set of
sums where I'm only
taking sums across edges in g.
So, in particular, if G is
the complete bipartite graph,
then this is the usual sumset.
But now I may allow
G to be a subset
of the complete bipartite graph.
So only taking some
but not all of the--
only taking-- yes, some of
this sums but not all of them.
The graphical version of
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
says that if you have A and B
be subsets of an Abelian group,
both having size,
at most, n, and G
is a bipartite graph
between A and B,
such that G has lots of
edges, has at least n squared
over k edges.
If the restricted sumset
between A and B is small--
So here we're not looking at all
the sums but a large fraction
of the possible pairwise sums.
If that sumset has
small size, this
is kind of like a restricted
doubling constant.
Then there exists
A prime, subset
of A, B prime, subset of
B, with A prime and B prime
both fairly large fractions
of their parent set,
and such that the unrestricted
sumset between A prime and B
prime is not too large.
So let me say it again.
So we have a fairly dense--
so a constant
fraction edge density,
a fairly dense bipartite
graph between A and B. A and B
are subsets of
the Abelian group.
Then-- and such that the
restricted sumset is small.
Then I can restrict A and B to
subsets, fairly large subsets,
so that the complete sumset
between the subsets A prime
and B prime is small.
Let me show you why the
graphical version of BSG
implies the version of
BSG I stated up there.
But, so why do we care about
this graphical version?
Well, suppose we-- so we
have all of these hypotheses.
Let's write-- so we have all
of those hypotheses up there.
So let's write r
to be r sub A comma
B, so I don't have to carry
the subscripts all around.
What do you think--
so I start with
A and B up there,
and I need to
construct that graph G.
So what should we
choose as our graph?
Let's consider the popular sums.
So the popular sums are
going to be elements
in the complete
sumset such that it
is represented as a sum
in many different ways.
And we're going to take
edges that correspond
to these popular sums.
So let's consider
bipartite graph G such
that A comma B is an edge if and
only A plus B is a popular sum.
So let's verify some
of the hypotheses.
So we're going to
assume graph BSG,
and let's verify the
hypothesis in graph BSG.
On one hand, because
each element of S
is a popular sum, if we
consider its multiplicity,
we find that the size of S
multiplied by n over 2k, lower
bound be size of A
times the size of B.
So if you think about all the
different pairs in A and B,
each sum here, each popular
sum, contributes this many times
to this A cross B.
So, as a result, because
size of A and size of B
are both, at most, n, we
find that the size of S
is, at most, 2kn.
And if you think
about what G is,
then this implies also that the
restricted sumset of A and B
across this graph G--
which only requires
the popular sums.
So the restricted sumset is
precisely the popular sums.
So restricted sumset
is not too large.
OK, good.
So we got one of the conditions,
that the restricted sumset
is not too large.
And now we want to show that
this graph has lots of edges.
It has lots of edges.
And here's where we would need
to use the hypothesis that,
between A and B, originally
there is large additive energy.
And the point here is that
these unpopular sums cannot
contribute very much to the
additive energy in total,
because each one of
them is unpopular.
So the dominant contributions
to the additive energy
are going to come
from the popular sums,
and we're going to use that to
show that G has lots of edges.
So let's lower bound the number
of edges of G by first showing
that--
so we'll show that the unpopular
sums contribute very little
to the additive energy
between A and B. Indeed,
the sums of the squares
of the r's, if for x
not in popular sums,
is upper bounded by--
well, claim that
it is upper bounded
by the following quantity,
that n over 2k times n squared.
Because I can take
out one factor r,
upper bound by this
number, just by definition,
and the sums of the
r's is n squared.
So you have this additive
energy between A and B.
I know that it is
large by hypothesis.
Whereas, I also know
that I can write it
as a sum of the squares
of the r's, which
I can break into the
popular contributions
and the unpopular contributions.
And, hopefully,
this should all be
somewhat reminiscent of
basically all these proofs
that we did so far
in this course,
where we separate a sum
into the dominant terms
and the minor terms.
This came up in Fourier
analysis in particular.
So we do this
splitting, and we upper
bound the unpopular
contributions by the estimate
from just now.
So, as a result, bringing
this small error term,
it doesn't cancel
much of the energy.
So we still have a lower bound
on the sum of the squares
of the r's in the popular sums.
But I can also give a fairly
trivial upper bound to a single
r, namely it cannot
be bigger than n.
And so the number
of edges of G--
so what's the number
of edges of G?
Look at that.
Each x here contributes
rx many edges.
So the number of edges of G is
simply the sums of these rx's.
Which is quite large.
So the hypothesis of
graph BSG are satisfied.
And so we can use the
conclusion of graph BSG, which
is the conclusion that
we're looking for in BSG.
Any questions?
Good.
So the remaining
task is to prove
the graphical version of BSG.
So let's take a
quick break, and when
we come back we'll
focus on this theorem,
and it has some nice
graph theoretic arguments.
OK, let's continue.
We've reduced the proof of the
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers theorem
to the following
graphical result.
Well, it's not just
graphical, right?
Still-- we're still inside
some an Abelian group,
still looking at some set
in some Abelian group,
but, certainly, now it has
a graph attached to it.
Let me show this theorem
through several steps.
First, something called
a path of length 2 lemma.
So the path of length
2 lemma, the statement
is that you start
with a graph G which
is a bipartite graph
between vertex sets A and B.
And now A and B no longer need--
they're just sets.
They're just vertex sets.
We're not going to have sums.
And the number of edges is
at least a constant fraction
of the maximum possible.
Then the conclusion
is that there
exists some U, a subset of A,
such that U is fairly large.
And between most pairs
of elements of U--
so between 1 minus epsilon
fraction of pairs of U--
there are lots of
common neighbors.
So at least epsilon
delta squared
B over 2 common neighbors.
So you start with this bipartite
graph A and B. Lots of edges.
And we would like
to show that there
exists a pretty large subset U
such that between most pairs--
all but an epsilon fraction--
of ordered pairs--
they could be the same,
but it doesn't really matter--
the number of paths of length
2 between these two vertices
is quite large.
So they have lots
of common neighbors.
Where have we seen
something like this before?
There's a question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
[INAUDIBLE] epsilon?
YUFEI ZHAO: Ah, yes.
So for every epsilon
and every delta.
So let epsilon,
delta be parameters.
Where have we seen
something like this before?
So in a bipartite graph
with lots of edges,
I want to find a large
subset of one of the parts
so that every pair of
elements, or almost
every pair of elements, have
lots of common neighbors.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
YUFEI ZHAO: Dependent
random choice.
So in the very first
chapter of this course,
when we did extremal
graph theory
forbidding bipartite
subgraphs, there
was a technique for proving the
extremal number, upper bounds,
for bipartite graphs
of bounded degree.
And there we used something
called dependent random choice
that had a conclusion that
was very similar flavor.
So there, we had every pair--
so a fairly large, but not as
large as this-- a
fairly large subset
where every pair of elements
had lots of common neighbors.
For every couple, every
k couple of vertices,
have lots of common neighbors.
So it's very similar.
In fact, it's the
same type of technique
that we'll use to prove
this lemma over here.
So who remembers how
dependent random choice goes?
So the idea is that we
are going to choose U
not uniformly at random.
So that's not going to work.
Going to choose it in
a dependent random way.
So I want elements of U to
have lots of common neighbors,
typically.
So one way to guarantee
this is to choose U to be
a neighborhood from the right.
So pick a random
element in B and choose
U to be its neighborhood.
So let's do that.
So we're going to use
dependent random choice.
See, everything in the
course comes together.
So let's pick v an element
of B uniformly at random.
And let U be the neighborhood
v. So, first of all,
by linearity of
expectations, the size of U
is at least delta of A. So
because the average degree
from the right from B is
at least delta A just based
on the number of edges.
If you have two vertices
a and a prime in A
with a small number of common
neighbors, then the size of--
so sorry.
Let me-- I skipped ahead a bit.
So if a and a prime have a small
number of common neighbors,
then the probability that
a and a prime both lie in U
should be quite small.
Because if they both had--
if a and a prime have a small
number of common neighbors,
in order for a and a prime
to be included in this U,
you must have chosen--
so suppose this were
their common neighbor.
Then in order that a and
a prime be contained in U,
it must have chosen this v to be
inside the common neighborhood
of a and a prime.
Which is unlikely
if a and a prime
had a small number
of common neighbors.
So this probability is, at most,
epsilon delta squared over 2.
Just think about how
U is constructed.
So if we let x be the number
of a and a primes in U cross U
with, at most, epsilon
delta squared over 2 times B
common neighbors, then, by
linearity of expectations,
the expectation of x is--
well, by summing up all of these
probabilities of a and a prime,
both being in U--
so this is, at most,
epsilon delta squared
over 2 times size of A squared.
So, typically, at
least in expectation,
you do not expect very
many pairs of elements in U
with few common neighbors.
But we can also turn
such an estimate
into a specific instance.
And the way to do this is to
consider the quantity size of U
squared minus x over epsilon.
Well, first of all, we can
lower bound this quantity,
because the size of
second moment of U
is at least the first
moment of U squared.
And we also know that the
size of x in expectation
is not very large.
So the whole expression
can be lower bounded
by delta squared over 2
times the size of A squared.
So this is epsilon, sorry.
Therefore, there is
some concrete instance
of this randomness resulting
in some specific U such
that this inequality holds.
So there exists some U such
And, in particular, we find
that the size of U is at least--
just forget about
this minus term--
is at least that right-hand
side, square root.
So, in particular, the
size of U is at least
delta over 2 times
the size of A.
And, just looking at the
left-hand side, which
must be a non-negative quantity
because the right-hand side is
non-negative, we find that
x is, at most, an epsilon
fraction of U squared.
So putting these
together, we arrive
at the path of length 2 lemma.
So let me go through it again.
So this is the dependent
random choice method,
where we're going to--
we want to find this U,
where most pairs
of vertices in U
have lots of common neighbors.
So we start from the right side.
We start from B, pick a
uniform random vertex, which
you call v, and let U be
the neighborhood of v.
And I claim that this
U, typically, should
have the desired property.
And the reason is that, if
you have a pair of vertices
on the left that do not
have many common neighbors,
then I claim it is highly
unlikely that these two
vertices both appear in U.
Because for them to both appear
in U, your v have been selected
inside the common neighborhood
of a and a prime, which is
unlikely if a and a prime
have few common neighbors.
So, as a result,
the expected number
of pairs in U with small number
of common neighbors is small.
And, already, that's
a very good indication
that we're on the right track.
And, to finish
things off, we look
at this expression, which we
can lower bound by convexity.
And we know the size of U
in expectation is large.
And, also, the size of
x, that we just saw,
is small in expectation.
So you have this
inequality over here.
And because there's
an expectation,
it implies that there's some
specific instance such that,
without the expectation,
the inequality holds.
So take that specific instance.
We obtain some U such that
this inequality is true,
which simultaneously
implies that U is large
and x, the number of
bad pairs, is small.
So that was dependent
random choice.
Any questions?
All right.
So that was the path
of length 2 lemma.
So it tells us I
can take a large set
with lots of paths of length 2
between most pairs of vertices.
Let's upgrade this lemma to
a path of length 3 lemma.
So, in the path
of length 3 lemma,
we start with a bipartite graph,
as before, between A and B.
So G is a bipartite
between A and B.
And, as before, we have a
lot of edges between A and B.
It's the delta fraction
of all possible edges.
Then the conclusion is that
there exists A prime in A and B
prime subset of B such
that A prime and B
prime are both large
fractions of their parent set.
And now, the-- and,
furthermore, every pair
between A prime and
B prime is joined
by many paths of length 3.
So a path of length 3
means there's 3 edges.
And, here, this eta is basically
the original error term
up to a polynomial change.
So starting with this bipartite
graph that's fairly dense,
the lemma tells us
that we can find
some large A prime
and large B prime so
that between every vertex in
A prime and every vertex in B
prime, there are lots of paths
of length 3 between them.
Every time.
So we should think about
all of these constants as--
plus you only make polynomial
changes in the constants,
we're happy.
Here, eta is a polynomial
change in the delta.
There's a convention which I
like which is not universal,
but it's often solved,
unlike this convention.
It's the difference
between the little c
and the big C is that
a little c is better
if you make it smaller,
and a big C is better--
I mean, it's better in
the sense that if this
is true for little
c and big C, and you
make little c smaller and big C
bigger, then it is still true.
So big C is a sufficiently
large constant,
and little c is a
sufficiently small constant.
Just a--
So let's see the path of
length 3 lemma, see it's proof.
We're going to use the
path of length 2 lemma,
but we need a bit of
preparation first.
So the proof has some nice
ideas, but it's also--
some parts of it are slightly
tedious, so bear with me.
So we're going to construct
a chain of subsets A--
inside A. So A1, A2, A3.
And this is just because
there's a few cleaning up
steps that need to be done.
Let's call two
vertices in A friendly
if they have lots
of common neighbors.
And, precisely,
we're going to say
they're friendly if they
have more than delta
squared over 80 times the
size of B common neighbors.
Let me construct this sequence
of subsets as follows.
First, let A1 be all
the vertices in A
with degree not too small.
So this is in preparation.
So it will make our life
quite a bit easier later on.
Let's just trim all the
really small degree vertices
so that we don't have
to think about them.
So you trim all the
small degree vertices.
And think about how
many edges you trim.
You cannot trim so many edges,
because each time you trim such
a vertex, you only get rid
of a small number of edges.
So, in the end, at least half
of the original set of edges
must remain.
And, as a result, the
size of A1 is at least
a delta over 2 fraction of
the original vertex set.
Otherwise, you could
not have contained half
of the original set of edges.
So this is the
first trimming step.
So we got rid of some edges, but
we got rid of fewer than half
of the original edges.
And because now you have
a minimum degree on A1,
the number of edges
between A1 and B
is quite large,
still quite large.
So think about passing
down to A1 now.
In the second step, we are going
to apply the path of length 2
lemma to this A1.
So A2 is going to be
constructed from--
so using the path
of length 2 lemma,
specifically with parameter
epsilon being delta over 10.
Although, remember, now
the density of the graph
went from delta to delta over 2.
Again, if you don't care
about the specific numbers,
they're all
polynomials in delta.
So don't worry about them.
Everything's poly delta.
So we're going to apply
the path of length 2 lemma
to find this subset A2.
And it has the property
that A2 is quite large,
and all but a small fraction
of pairs in A2 are friendly.
So we passed down to, first,
trimming small degree vertices,
and then passed
down further to A2,
where all but a small
fraction of elements in A2,
or all but a small
fraction of the pairs
are friendly to each
other, meaning they
have lots of common neighbors.
And now let's look
at the other side.
Let's look at B. So
we're in this situation
now where you have--
so we're now in a situation
where you've passed down
to A2 and in B, where, because
of what we did initially,
every vertex in here
have large degree.
So there's this minimum
degree condition
from every vertex on the left.
So the average degree
is still very high.
As a result, the
average degree from B
is going to be quite high.
So let's focus on the B side
and pick out vertices in B
that have high degree.
So let's B1 denote
vertices in B such
that the degree from B
to A2 is at least half
of what you expect
based on average degree.
And, as before, the same
logic as the A1 step.
We see that B1 has large size,
is a large fraction of B.
And now we pass
down to this B1 set.
Now, finally, let's consider
A3 to be vertices in A2
where a is friendly.
So vertices a in A2 such that
a is friendly to at least 1
over delta over--
so 1 minus delta over
5 fraction of A2.
So we saw that, in A2, most
pairs of vertices are friendly.
So most, meaning all but
a delta over 10 fraction.
So if we consider
vertices which are
unfriendly to many
other vertices in A2,
there aren't so many of them.
If there were many of them,
you couldn't have had that.
So that's why I
constructed this set
A3 consisting of
elements in A2 that
are friendly to many elements.
And the size of A3 is at
least half of that of A2.
So we have this A3 inside.
All right.
And now I claim that we can
take A3 and B as our final sets,
and that between every vertex
in A3 and every vertex in B1,
I claim there must be
lots of paths of length 3.
But, first, let's
check their sizes.
I mean, the sizes all should
be OK, because we never
lost too much at each step.
If you only care about
polynomial factors,
well, you already see that
we never lost anything more
than a polynomial factor.
But just to be precise, the
size of A3 is at least--
so if you count up the
factor lost at each step,
so it's 1/2 delta
over 4 delta over 2.
So it's at least delta
squared over 16 fraction
of the original set A.
And now, if we
consider a comma b
to be an arbitrary
pair in A3 cross B1,
I claim that there
must be many paths.
Because by using-- so what
properties do we know?
We know that b is adjacent
to a large fraction.
So here large means at least
delta over 4-- so bounded
below-- a large fraction of A2.
Yes.
So I apologize.
When I say the word large,
depending on context
it can mean bigger than delta,
or it could mean at least 1
minus delta.
So you look at
what I write down.
So b is adjacent to at least
delta over 4 fraction of A2.
At the same time, we know that
a is friendly to at least 1
minus delta over
5 fraction of A2.
So these two sets, they must
overlap by at least a delta
over 20 fraction.
So let's take a vertex b.
So you-- so it's adjacent
to many vertices here.
And if you look
at a vertex in A,
it's friendly to
a large fraction.
So, in particular, it's
friendly to all these elements
over here.
So, to finish off, what
does it mean for a--
this is-- this vertex is a.
This vertex is b.
What does it mean for
a to be friendly to all
of these shaded elements?
It means that there are
lots of paths from a
to each of these elements.
And then you can finish off
the paths going back to b.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The shaded stuff is
allowed to be outside of A3?
YUFEI ZHAO: No. the
shaded-- the question
is, is the shaded stuff
allowed to be outside of A3?
No.
The shaded things are inside A3.
So we're looking at
intersections within A3.
No, sorry.
Actually, no, you're right.
So the shaded things
can be outside A3.
So shaded things
I apologize.
So everything now is in A2.
So b is adjacent to a
large fraction of A2.
And a here is friendly to some
part of the neighbors of b.
So you can complete
paths like that.
Yes.
So only the starting
and ending points
have to be in A
prime and B prime.
Everything else, they can go
outside of the A prime and B
prime.
Yes, thank you.
So the number of paths from
a to B to A2 back to b is--
let's see if I can
stay within B1--
so is at least--
yes.
So it's-- sorry.
This is B. So it's at least
delta over 20 times A2 times
delta over delta squared
over 80 times B. So
if you don't care about
polynomial factors in delta,
then you see that--
the point is there's
a large fraction of--
there are a lot of paths.
So there are a lot of paths
between each little a and each
little b by the
construction we've done.
So let me just do a recap.
So there were quite a few
details in this proof,
and some of them have
to do with cleaning up.
Because it's not so
nice to work with graphs
that just have large
average degree.
It's much nicer to
work with graphs
with large minimum degree.
So there are a couple of steps
here to take care of vertices
with small degrees.
So we started with, between
A and B, lots of edges.
And we trim vertices
from A with small degree.
So we get A1.
And then we apply the path
of length 2 lemma to get A2.
So inside A2, most
pairs of vertices
have lots of common
neighbors, but not all.
We then go back to
B to get B1, which
has large minimum degree to A2.
And then A3 looks
at vertices in A
with many friendly
companions in A2.
And A3 is large, and I claim
that between every vertex in A3
and every vertex in B, you
have many paths of length 3.
Because if you start
with a vertex in A3,
it has many friendly companions.
So many here means at least 1
minus delta over 5 fraction.
Whereas every vertex in B1
has lots of neighbors in A2,
where lots means at
least delta over 4.
So there's
necessarily an overlap
of at least delta over 20.
And for that overlap,
we can create
lots of paths going
through this overlap from A
to B. Any questions?
OK, great.
So let's put everything together
to prove the graphical version
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers.
So we'll prove the
graphical version
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers.
So by-- so, first, note
that the hypothesis
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
already
implies that the size
of A and the size of B
are not too small.
Because, otherwise, you couldn't
have had n squared over k edges
to begin with.
So by the path of
length 3 lemma,
there exists A prime
in A and B prime
in B with the
following properties.
That A prime has a
large fraction of--
so A prime and B prime
are both large in size.
And for all vertices
a in A prime
and vertices b in
B prime, there are
lots of paths of length
3 between these vertices.
So there are at least k
to the minus little o1--
to the minus big
O1 times n squared
pairs of intermediate
vertices a1,
b1 in A cross B, such that
a b1 a1 b is a path in G.
So let me draw the
situation for you.
So we have A and B.
And so inside A and B,
we have this fairly
large A prime
and B prime, such that
for every little a
and little b, there are
many paths like that
going to b1 and a2.
Let me set-- so let me set
x to be a plus b1, that sum,
y to be a1 plus b1,
and z to be a1 plus b.
So now notice that we can write
this a plus b in at least k
to the minus big O1
times n squared ways
as x minus y plus z by
following this path, where x, y,
and z all lie in the
restricted sumset,
because that's how the
restricted sumset is defined.
So if you have an edge,
then the sum of the elements
across on the two
ends, by definition,
lies in the restricted sumset.
So the path of length
3 lemma tells us
that every pair a
and b, their sum
can be written in many different
ways as this combination.
As a result, we see that
A prime plus B prime--
so this sum, if we consider sum
along with its multiplicity--
so now we're really looking at
all the different sums as well
as ways of writing the
sum as this combination--
we see that it is bounded above
by the restricted sumset raised
to the third power.
Because each of these
choices, x, y, and z,
they come from the
restricted sumset.
But the hypothesis of
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers,
the graphical version, is
that the restricted sumset
is small in size.
So we can now upper bound
the restricted sumset
by, basically, the--
within a constant, within a
factor of the maximum possible.
And now we are done,
because we have deduced
that the complete sumset
between A prime and B prime
is, at most, a constant
factor with change
in constant by a polynomial.
So a constant factor more
than the maximum possible.
So it's, at mostly, k to
the big O1 poly k times n.
So that proves the
graphical version
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers.
And because we showed earlier
that the graphical version
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
implies Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers,
this shows the
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers theorem.
So let me recap some of
the ideas we saw today.
And so the whole point
of Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers
and all of these related lemmas
and theorems and variations
is that you start with
something that has
a lot of additive structure.
Well, after we passed down to
graphs just a lot of edges.
So you start with
a situation where
you have kind of 1% goodness.
And you want to
show that you can
restrict to fairly
large subsets,
so that you have perfection.
So you have complete goodness
between these two sets.
And this is what's going on
in both the graphical version
and the additive version.
So back to the graph
path of length 3 lemma.
So we were able to boost the
path of length 2 lemma, which
tells us something about
99% of the pairs having lots
of common neighbors, to
100% of the pairs having
lots of path of length 3.
And in the additive
setting, we saw that
by starting with a situation
where the hypothesis is
somewhat patchy, so like
a 1% type hypothesis,
we can pass down to
fairly large sets, where
the complete sumset, starting
with just the restricted sumset
being small, can pass
down to large sets
where the complete
sumset is small.
And this is an important
principle, that, often,
when we have some typicality
by an appropriate argument--
and, here, it's not at
all a trivial argument.
So there's some
cleverness involved,
that by doing some
kind of argument,
we may be able to pass down
to some fairly large set
where it's not typically
good, but everything's
perfectly good.
That's the spirit here of the
Balog-Szemeredi-Gowers theorem.
So, next time, for the last
lecture of this course,
I will tell you about
the sum-product problem,
where the--
there are also some graph-- very
nice graph theoretic inputs.